son rêve s'est effondré le jour où cette
déchetterie faisant face à son vignoble
a été agrandie reynald et au lait est un
viticulteur indépendant depuis 2010 est
en janvier 2019 il obtient les permis de
construire sont chères pour y conserver
et faire déguster ses vins ainsi que sa
maison car il souhaite vivre dans son
exploitation
mais en septembre de la même année la
communauté de communes des terres du val
de loire lance la réhabilitation et
l'agrandissement de la déchetterie
destiné à devenir quatre fois plus
grande en est clairement pour reynald
qui se voit mal cultiver et vendre du
vin bio
face à ce site important de collecte de
déchets moi je vais faire quoi demain là
j'ai repris des vignes à quatre ans le
temps de remettre en état d'y repasser
en bio tout ça là sont arrêtés en pleine
forme
j'avais besoin de mon chez pour
justement le vinifier logeaient les
raisins les bouteilles des tonneaux je
peux plus faire long chez ici c'est
totalement incompatible avec la
déchetterie scène met une balle dans le
pied
donc je fais quoi des vignes que j'ai
reprise donc ça veut dire que demain
quand je dis demain c'est dans six mois
je suis obligé d'abandonner la moitié de
mailing donc c'est une mort économique
mais reynaldo ne baisse pas les bras et
décide de croiser le fer il reproche aux
élus de ne pas avoir discuté avec lui de
leur projet avant de le lancer mais
également de lui avoir accordé un permis
de construire antérieur à celui de la
déchetterie
sans même prendre soin de l'informer de
leur décision de l'agrandir pour la
président de la communauté de communes
des terres du val de loire c'est
l'étonnement
il ya eu maldonne à un moment donné
entre le projet en face de la
déchetterie de ce viticulteur qui
installe et quand même son son chai en
face de la déchetterie existantes sépare
il le savait il y avait déjà une
déchetterie moi je n'ai eu absolument
aucune information sur le la
construction duché avant novembre 2020
peter ne s'est jamais manifesté il ne
s'est manifestée qu'au mois de novembre
2020 même si la présidente de la
communauté des communes assure qu'elle
souhaite trouver une issue en dénichant
nouveau terrain pour reynald et en lui
faisant grâce des frais d'un nouveau
permis de construire
le vigneron d'y avoir décelé des
incohérences dans cette offre et dénonce
une volonté de passer en force il a
décidé de porter l affaire en justice